How your uni option modules
will result in you getting a first class degree
has got to be like
the biggest advice I can give.
But of course
it is very between different uni,
kind of like specs and stuff.
But in my last year of uni
we have full discretion over what we could have studied
and we got to choose, um,
three modules.
So I did employment law,
advanced criminal law
and I did family law.
I got first class in all those modules
because those are modules I really,
really liked.
Like however many option modules you have
available on your course,
that can increase your percentage of
getting a very high grade in your degree.
So make sure.
I think the three things I'd say to kind of consider
is choose an option module you will like
or you think you will like.
Have a look at kind of the speck of it
and kind of the themes and the content,
whether it is content you can easily understand
or content that you will maybe like.
So just kind of making a list on, like,
laws you like and laws you don't like.
Look at the exam
kind of assessment.
How are you going to get assessed on each module?
So for example,
for my second year
medical law
we had I think
50% group work,
50% it was a problem question.
And then for child protectional
it was literally an essay.
So see how your Assessments are out for
if you're more of an exam person.
And see if you can find multiple choice,
like kind of modules
or modules that have
like 24 hour exams.
Or if you're more of like
an assignment kind of person,
go for your problem questions.
Go for assignments.
Research projects,
they like all the good ones.
And I excelled more in the research projects
and the proper questions
rather than kind of the multiple choice questions.
So it's all up to like,
your own individual learning style.
This video helps.